We were so obsessed with the little
things that didn't matter
like the of a specific button or
the specific experience when the user
is clicking back but is not logged in.
All kinds of side things that won't move
the needle and doesn't really matter.
And it's very important to make sure
that the experience is perfect and
you're nailing it on the first time but
you need to make sure that the product
is right and not the buttons.
Need to make sure the general flow and
the problem that is being solved
with your product is right, and
not the specific background color or
the perfect logo or
the responsiveness of the website
because that's optimisation.
You do that in the AB testing part.
You do that after you nail your MVP but
we did that before we
met them MVP and we waited a lot of
time on that and I wish we hadn't.
It will not happen again.